all right we're back for episode two of
coding this little demo rpg if you
haven't seen the first one highly
recommend watching it otherwise it's
going to be a little bit lost
but basically we kind of finished the hp
class so we're going to start designing
the rest and now i also turned that
little text file into a readme so i'm
going to bring up my terminal here
code of readme it's going to open up
visual studio code and we can just see
that i'm going to put it in
preview mode so you can see what it
would look like on github but yeah
so we see this this is still what we're
going for the design in mind
yada yada
i guess i'll kind of do the same thing
of putting it off to the side like we
did last time but this time
we're just going to be using this thing
all right hey that looks pretty good
all right so uh yeah we got the hit
points worked out let's keep working on
the classes and then we can get to the
rest of the stuff
and we're going to start with the
warrior but i want to concept a few
things real quick first
and that is
the hit point growth all right so
warrior is going to be the highest hit
points
so let's just add a few things to this
readme
warriors highest hit points very well
very very good so maybe i'll correct
this a little more outside video but
basically
i want to have like the hp growth the
highest on the warrior and maybe we'll
randomize a little bit but
yeah so like maybe we'll start we'll
just say 10 10 is a good number that's
what dnd uses
that's a little bit low for a computer
game
it's good for dice but for computers
but we want a little bit bigger and i
don't want to copy dandy but it's just
such a classic and goes back to like the
70s that it's hard not to have it as a
uh what's the inspiration if you will
but we're more like designing our own
road like with some just traditional
classes as a demo nothing even serious
uh i guess you know it
yeah i'll leave it at that so
we'll just put like hp growth
and we'll say it's uh
we'll say it's 20. so maybe they gain 20
hit points to per level or something
like that where they start out with 20.
and i i don't want this to take too long
but
yeah and we're going to say the wizard
hp growth is going to be
let's just say 10 that's kind of like
the lowest
all right and we'll say the cleric
hp growth
is
uh we'll say
we'll say 15.
i feel like rogue and clerica should be
pretty similar on this but that's just
my opinion also say prediction
and i'm going to change the warrior to
uh highest
damage reduction
because i like that that sounds good
that that kind of goes with the theme of
big armor
big tank big tanky boy and maybe we'll
reduce these hp's just a little bit you
know it's like tweaks don't you hate it
when games they decide to nerf something
and instead of like mine just tweaking
it a tiny bit down they're just like
nerf it into the ground no longer
playable no we're not going to do that
we're going to keep it playable we'll
just do a little tiny incremental
changes if something doesn't feel right
i feel like maybe this will be better at
19. you know it's stuff like that all
right
listen to the wise yes players hate when
you nerf or buff things beyond insanity
just little increments dabs little
increments
it's a lot easier to follow a lot easier
to work with for us players so we're
gonna go with that so we're going to
that's going to we're going to kind of
use these growth systems for leveling
them up so like naturally over time the
warrior will have a bigger pool and you
can see where this is going i don't
think i need to explain any further but
i think i'm actually going to have the
rope just a tiny bit lower than the
cleric that that feels right to me
so there we go
all right
and we're going to start building these
and this session
all right now that we got that theory
crafting out of the way let's just go
ahead and make a class now i was
thinking here do we want a base class
or do we want to do this in a different
way and i feel like since these are
going to be like core parts and then the
core four if you will we're going to
just oh it's snowing outside nice uh
we're gonna just
make them each their own thing and for
now we're just going to build them in
headers just like last time let's start
with the warrior all right warrior
sounds good so we're going to go class
warrior
and we're going to publicly inherit from
hp because it's got an hp pool now if we
design other parts of the class that are
reusable
we can do the same thing and this hp of
course is also going to be used later
for like monsters and all that stuff
bosses npcs whatever we may have so
that's one of the sweet things about
this sort of design is once you design
something like your hp
you can reuse it everywhere you don't
have to keep rewriting these systems
it's awesome and if something changes in
it it automatically changes throughout
all of them you don't have to change it
all over the place it's it's the beauty
of
inheritance
okay so it doesn't know about hp because
we have to include the header file
that's pretty standard there so we'll do
that all right so now we already have
all the functions from hp ready to go
all we really need
well
this doesn't have a constructor so when
it's it's not going to even set hp or
max hp to anything there
they're probably just going to be
bad values that aren't you know we don't
have constructors is what i'm trying to
say here and that's kind of kind of a
bad thing but we could go ahead and give
it a default constructor
and i think we want to do that by way it
sets to something
so we'll do that we'll just make a
default constructor here and we'll just
go hp
give it some brackets there and we'll
type in whatever we want to be we'll go
current hp equals
maybe we'll just set them both to one
that sounds fine with me
oops max hp
just one so yeah they just if they don't
declare what they are you're just going
to get a one
and there we go very good so now what's
going to happen is we'll declare our
lawyer give it a default constructor
and it is going to call the hp default
constructor constructors could be one
but if we want to set our own stuff for
that
we could do it a slightly different way
because like uh maybe we want another
constructor here in hp
that we can pass in a few variables like
we pass in hp type
for uh
chp for current hp
and we can pass in hp type
uh mhp
and what that will do is just set them
to whatever we say we'll say
that current hp
equals
chp
so that way we can pass in values for
what we want them to start as
now this could we could throw this off
because we could pass in bad numbers
that don't make any sense here like we
could give more current hp than max hp
those things you've got to think about
when you're designing stuff like this
and
yeah that's something to consider
so
we'll make that
uh make sense as much as we can here
now one way we could do that is we could
call our functions
instead of setting it directly or we
could put some logic in this constructor
either way would really be fine
i'd like i i like the idea of putting
some some logic in here
so i'll just put like if
and so after you set them
in the same functions it's going to be
in the same thread
yeah we're not really thinking about
multi-threading here this is all single
threaded i didn't really talk about that
any in the first episode but in general
we're staying single threaded we could
very well get into multi-threaded but
it's going to be a whole nother realm of
things we have to think about and care
about it might be important later if
this keeps growing and becomes a
multitude of things but as it is just a
little simple system
any processor on even a phone or a
calculator these days it's going to be
plenty fast enough to handle this sort
of thing without you noticing any lag so
there's really no need to go
multi-threaded although if we wanted to
show off we could but i'm not in a show
off emote mood and
i always have to look up a ton of things
when i do multi-threading because i'm
not i'm not a big multi-threaded guy i
do it sometimes when i have to
uh but uh usually i avoid it until it
becomes necessary
but ninety percent of the time if you if
you feel like things aren't working well
or aren't optimized well enough
and you think multi-threading is the
answer it's usually not usually a better
algorithm will solve it
because i see that all the time someone
says oh this is too slow let's
multi-thread it so they take their
terribly slow algorithm and they
multi-thread it and it's still terribly
slow it just uses up more of their
processor
you know it's better to first sort out
your algorithm and then multi-thread now
that's just my opinion and take away but
take that for what you will so we'll say
if current hp is greater than max hp
uh we'll just correct it basically and
we'll just say current b equals max hp
and that should take care of it
no big deal really pretty simple thing
so there we go so now we could use this
constructor as well and i think that's
what we're gonna do so in our warrior
here
we are going to
call it in a special way i need to make
this bigger i realized in the last
episode that it was really small uh
so i'll try to remember to make these
bigger for you guys
so
since we're inheriting from
this hp
we can
use it in our constructor we can go hp
we can put in whatever numbers we want
here so we are going to want those hp
types and of course they're unsigned in
16 so what do we what do we want we want
this the starting number right
and we can mark those down somewhere we
probably want to do that so let's think
about how to do this all right let's
think about a few things here
all right first things first okay so we
said the warriors hp growth is going to
be 19. that's going to be like that for
all warriors
regardless of
how many we instantiate how many
different warriors happen to be in the
world running around having you in your
party i'm going to have the same hp
growth rate of 19. so what we don't want
to do because it would be bad design
is have this variable hp growth
oops and a bunch of different spots in
our program so
one way we can do that one way we can
fix this up is right in our class here
we could have well let's make sure to
make this public up here
uh blick
uh we'll put private down here in case
we need it
but
yeah so we got a public constructor here
if you just construct a base warrior
it's going to do the space thing
we could make a static variable
static
honest uh hp growth
and
uh wait we need a type uh well hp type
hp type
and it's named hp gross equals
19.
uh i think if we put a u here does that
make it inside yeah i think that's right
okay maybe we'll make this all caps
so now
static in a class basically means that
only one of these is going to be
instantiated and since it's const it
cannot be changed so no matter how many
warriors you make the static const is
only going to be is only going to happen
once throughout your program so as you
might have noticed from last episode
yeah this hp type is 4 bytes wide now if
we instantiated it just like this
this would mean
that each every time you instantiate a
warrior every time you make a new
warrior in your game
it recreates this variable you use four
more bytes of memory
and uh that might be okay it's not much
but
it's it's good to get used to optimizing
it's calling me at a time like this
okay just a spammer had to tell them off
real quick i don't think they heard me
anyway because they were probably a
robot but okay the point i was getting
to is if we make it static
it only ever instantiates once we no
matter how many warriors come into play
in our game we only
have this variable one time we're only
using four bytes never anymore and boom
bob's your uncle is that what they say
uh so just a little thing that you can
do to have a little optimization there
now
what are they doing these days are kids
doing const expert or something i don't
know whatever you can correct it on
github if you want to make pull requests
leave a little note if you want that's
fine but we're going to stick with this
this should work fine and it should do
exactly what i said basically so
all right
so now we have this variable ready to go
and we can we can just start it out like
that
so we'll put hp growth
right here
because we have current hp and a max hp
and we'll just set them to the same
and there we go now when we instantiate
a warrior by default
it is going to
i don't think we need that one there
okay
it's going to give them the max hp they
start out with their 19 hp very good
and it's going to be pretty efficient i
guess we could just do it like this
we don't have anything else to
initialize yet but
now we're getting to a point where we
need to decide
what other kind of things are these
classes going to have do they have
strength do they have endurance do they
have charisma you know stuff like that
uh
i think we're just going to keep it
super simple here we already got an hp
growth
pool that we're going to put custom in
each of them so that's kind of going to
work as the endurance constitution or
whatever
i think all we want is like maybe a
resistance yeah we're just going to go
with like a resistance and uh
power or strength
maybe we should have one for magic and
one for non-magic
this is one of those things where like
you could hypothesize a million
different things but we're just going to
keep it real simple
and we're going to we're going to do
we're going to go like intelligence
strength
yeah just intelligence and strength is
fine and that that's all we need because
the intelligence stat will be used for
like casting stuff and maybe a few other
checks or whatever uh but we don't want
to go too far we don't want to have like
multiple stats for physical and stuff
like that that's just too complicated
for a simple thing right now i mean you
can if you want but i don't think it's
going to be necessary and it doesn't
really help
add to the any of the points of of this
particular thing we're doing here
all right so let's do that now we're
going to reuse these now it's so if like
every living thing has hp and every
little living thing also has
a strength and intelligence
then maybe we also want something else
to inherit from that works with those
because now if you think about it
monsters are going to have the stat type
stuff
i like the hp growth being
separate per
class or per thing
i not piled in with the hit points
because it's going to be like specific
to this this warrior class or whatever
monster class we end up making down the
road
but uh for now
let's just add
yet another
class here
and we're just going to call this
uh stack block
yeah stack block
okay and our stat block it's just going
to be another class
and uh this one could probably even be a
struck now let's keep the class classes
fine see well i'll show you a different
way of doing this there's another way of
doing this this is kind of an older
style
so let's make a struct and we'll call it
stat lock stat block
spell it like that that's fine and we'll
have
uh okay so we want
now let's think about this
can you have negative strength can you
have negative intelligence how do we
want to calculate these do we want to do
intelligence like iq no probably not not
for a game that's not really going to
work well do we want to do strength like
like what how do we want to how do we
want to think of it you know we got to
come up with a system that works and
that's going to be able to like apply
property properly to abilities later
like if someone's doing magic uh what's
what's intelligence actually do is give
them more mana it's given more damage we
need to make these decisions
so we can design this the way we want so
let's make some decisions i'm going to
pause think about it and come up with my
personal solution and you can let me
know what you think or
whatever
all right so i decided i'm going to go
with a bit of a like a skyrim type
method you know how they go basically
from 1 to 100 i i think that feels quite
nice and if we're going 1 to 100
what kind of variable do we want to use
we don't necessarily want the hp type
because that goes to 65 000 right uh we
don't if we're going one to 100 we don't
want our variable to
be that giant we could go with a maybe
like that you went eight it can also
never be negative
so uh yeah i you went 8 would be fine
here because it only goes to 255 that's
beyond what we need but if we go any
smaller then we're getting a little too
small and that's not really going to
work i don't think there is no u n 4.
right or maybe there i don't know no one
uses that anymore it's just too small
these days
but you see the uh
the uint 8
quite frequently because it goes to 255.
it's a small little variable
it's just a 0xff right 0x ff
there we go
it's a base 16.
composed of two numbers and hex yep so
you can look up the stuff at will if you
want but
yeah you know we're really overkilling
this if we think about it so let's let's
make a new type uh maybe we don't even
yeah let's make a new type fine here we
go add oops i don't know what the heck i
just pressed all right add
new item
and we're going to make another header
we're going to call this one we're going
to
call this
stat
types there we go and so we'll make
another pipe depth
and it's going to be uh
standard unt
8
underscore
d and it's going to be stat
right
and we need to include c standard end
again
let's see standard and
there we go so now we can include this
file and say stat type anywhere we're
messing with those stats that are one to
one hundred so we're sticking with the
one to 100 now i might change that later
i can't promise you know maybe maybe
i'll get something stuck in my head with
that and we'll be like oh this doesn't
work or it's something like that we'll
see but for now
we're just going to go with that because
it doesn't use much memory and the
struct it should keep the struct really
small the stat block struct so we're
kind of minimalizing the memory there's
no you know we're on a super powerful
computer we don't need to do this
honestly but i'm just kind of trying to
teach you some some concepts is the
really the point here
and that way you can walk away with some
info you might not know if you're kind
of new but if you're a seasoned
professional you're going to be like
you're probably going to be like you're
doing it wrong or there's a better way
you know that that's not entirely the
point and maybe
that's all subjective really you can't
really say i'm doing it wrong to be
honest
because it's just too subjective all
right we need to include this class
or you could i don't know
a lot of coders once they get really
good they get really snarky just go on
stack overflow you'll figure it out it's
uh
they're no longer human the better you
get at coding the less human you become
i think that's a thing obviously i'm
meaning but it kind of seems true
doesn't it
so we're gonna include
uh step types that's what we want stat
type dot h
and we want double quotes around this
one
and uh
visual studio is trolling me
stop it okay there we go
now there's a little autocorrect stuff
all right so now that we have stat type
so we can go stat type
and
we want strength
and we want stat type
and select that's that's it
i think we'll stick with those
and if we want to add more later we can
uh pretty cool pretty cool
so
yeah so since this one is of size uh
yeah it was a
0xff and this one is of size
a 0x ff and this is only a 4 byte stat
block this is essentially the stat block
is going to be the size
of half an integer so in the size of
half an integer or
in the size of our hit point type
we get both of these and that's kind of
the beauty just kind of saving up a
little memory there now it might come
back to bite us later and some
calculations uh we'll have to address
that as it goes but that's kind of like
one of the advantages of doing stuff
like this and then and using the minimum
possible variable
so i hope that makes sense but it can be
very important especially if you're
doing like mem setting and stuff like
that which can become very relevant if
you're messing with the memory directly
we're kind of
latin
well we're kind of going to let the
compiler sort that out for us we're not
going to really be using too many
pointers and allocating our memory we're
just going to kind of
be letting that manually
so take that for what you will but
that's just to keep it simple and maybe
we will get into some pointer stuff
later we probably will once we're in
combat and stuff because we don't want
to be
passing and copying variables when
calling functions all the time we
probably want to be passing references
to uh
different
i don't know i'm losing i'm losing my
track of what i'm saying but you know
what i'm saying if you don't know what
i'm saying
we don't want to be copying these
variables we'd rather be copying the
memory location that's what i'm trying
to say which is basically a pointer so
we'll get to that later it's not really
too relevant in this uh particular part
come on brain don't fail me now let's
get through this
you ever have that moment yeah never
mind no i don't want to get too
sidetracked all right let's keep going
here
with our warrior so our warrior we're
now going to just include
also
stat block all right so we got hp we got
stat plot and we can publicly
uh inherit from that as well
stat block
so
public
is that the right way of doing it am i
doing something wrong
maybe oh okay i need i need some caps
there yeah that that's all that's wrong
there we just need some caps just that
now i'm kind of being a
a noob here like i should be
sticking with the same syntax
capitalizing here i'm not capitalizing
there that's a mess um
yeah okay
fine you're right i should be keeping it
the same all right so stat block
is just like that let's let's make like
a quick constructor in here too so stat
block
that way if they construct it with blank
we'll just go
strength
equals one
unsigned and intellect equals one
unsigned
should i be doing this a different way
if these are
uh
if i'm using these particular you went
eights should i not be using
u here one u because this is like
an unsigned in which usually resolves
the to a 32-bit integer so i might
actually be doing this slightly wrong
maybe like i should be casting
to a
stat type like like that
so uh i'm not entirely sure if someone
wants to like
correct and hit that on github you can
but uh
for sake of moving on we're just going
to move on but uh i'm i'm aware that
that's not necessarily correct
and that can be like a homework for
someone that wants to
get some some clout or whatever so
all right let's uh let's just move on so
we can just put it right in this
constructor with warrior we can say hey
our warrior's gonna be a little bit
beefier maybe he's got like a base
strength that's a little higher than
everyone else
and starts out a little bit higher so we
can also do like a similar thing here
for like
stat
stack type
uh base strength str
well maybe his base strength is like
um
well it's going to start out at 1 if we
don't specify so maybe we can say 10.
we'll start at 10. that sounds good and
that's something we didn't really put
over here in the design so we're just
coming up with this on the fly and also
do we want to cast these to the right
type
it doesn't hurt to do this and this is
actually an old c style casting we
should probably be doing static casting
uh but uh once again i'll leave that to
someone yeah that wants to
put the pull request on on github if
they're more wise i never said i was
like the the most knowledgeable uh top
level c plus plus coder there are
definitely people that are way more deep
in in the the magic of c plus plus than
i am i i just love it and i love to
learn but uh you know it's a
never-ending journey there's always so
much so if you have to learn if someone
wants to
to to show but
i will just leave this copy out because
this drives me crazy there's always
always someone in the comments that has
something clever to say
but does nothing to back it up and i
never believe you i don't believe you
okay i'm just gonna leave it at that
like if you leave leave in the comments
yes casting is correct i'm not gonna
believe you you know why because you
need some evidence all right uh leave
leave a link to a scholarly article that
says why or the proper place in the c
plus plus reference that says why leave
that link and then i'll believe you okay
just just throwing that out there drives
me crazy and i respond to a ton of these
people and i say like oh cool i'm glad
you know better can you show me where
you found the stuff none of them have
ever responded seriously zero people so
don't be that guy or if you are be or
that guy just back it up and you're cool
i love you but if you're not then you're
just a troll if you don't back it up
you're just a troll all right that's
just the way it is
all right
now i've got that out of the way
all right so we want to instantiate this
uh
stat block right stat
block
and
actually we're going to need
so that one defaults it to one let's
make another one here i just press ctrl
d there to duplicate that line and
let's say you're allowed to pass in some
stuff
so you're allowed to pass in a stat type
of the strength str i don't think is i
don't think you're allowed to use str so
we're just going to use s and you can
pass in stat type
you also can't use con i've learned that
before that you know i use con as a
variable name uh but uh that's another
point we'll just let's call this one i
so in this case we'll say
uh
i s and i here strength equals s on this
one
i guess i gotta zoom out this is like
too crowded now or maybe i could just
like separate this on the lines like a
normal human being and a normal coder
right
don't add me all right strength equals s
intellect equals
i
there
so that should do it so uh you know
there's another thing i haven't really
talked about and that is explicit
explicit
i think i'm doing it right but if you
say explicit that means
uh these are explicitly typed that means
you are
literally only allowed to pass in the
correct variable like this won't take
integers it won't take unsigned ins it
will only take whatever stat type is uh
it will only take you went eights
that's if you put explicit if you don't
put explicit this will take anything and
it will just convert it on fly so it's
if you want things to be strongly typed
and you don't want people to be like
playing around with conversions on the
fly
and you want them to make sure they know
what they're doing it's typically a good
idea to to put explicit am i doing this
right
it's typically a good idea to put
explicit on these to say hey you're
don't try to pass in something that's
over 256 right because
we already know
that uh these stat types as you went
eight it max is at 255. it's zero uh to
255. so if they tried to pass in an
unsigned in that was like 5000 or
something
what the heck is this gonna do we're not
even sure really so if we don't want to
allow that possibility we can strongly
type it with explicit it's just a c plus
plus keyword uh look it up read about it
if you don't know it it's a good one to
know very important
uh i'm kind of being very loose here
if someone wants to go strongly type
this on github that would be awesome go
show off your strongly typing skills uh
sure uh that'd be that'd be cool but
it's gonna sidetrack me a lot to go
correct all this right now so we're just
gonna leave this one explicit
that way
we know what we're doing here
but now what we can do is we can say uh
we can just put in some stat types here
uh of base strength
base strength and we want base end
and so we'll do the same thing here just
copy that line with ctrl d
uh base int ctrl b is a specific hotkey
on this editor yours might be different
or maybe you got to do some coffee pasta
manually
let's say
the warrior starts out with one hit
that's super low uh maybe you know these
can also be changed fly let's let's do a
five and a one or maybe we'll keep it a
little lower
and those four classes let's do one
through four
so we'll go like that yeah that's good
uh warrior has the the lowest analytic
because it gets knocked around in the
head the most that makes sense right
all right so very good now we're looking
really good here that we probably want
to strongly type this uh this hp
constructor and stuff but i'll uh
i'll move on from for now so we've got a
base warrior that we can instantiate as
many times as we want and when we just
give it a base instantiation he gets his
base stats and we've got these these
made in a way where they're pretty
efficient it's not going to repeat
making these these variables hey that's
not bad so we can pretty much copy pasta
this for the rest of the classes and
we're like we're smooth sailing you know
we got a nice uh base going
yeah there's some other ways i'm
thinking that this could be like
arranged but for sake of uh just moving
on and getting it done we're just gonna
we're just gonna create the other ones
and and move on so we got wizard there
uh we'll just copy like all of this
actually
over here
like that call this wizard
fold this wizard
change this hp growth
uh the nine
instead
yep nine that's what we agreed on change
the base strength to one and the base
into four just flip that around
on the wizard
super weak but super smart because their
heads in a book and their muscles are
atrophying that's the theory anyway that
seems to go with every rpg
and then next one we'll put the cleric
in there
the man of man of god if you will
uh i don't like how these classes are
kind of getting scattered but
i'm i'm gonna choose to not care for now
oh we need to recopy this
yeah just gonna choose to not care so
there there might be you know maybe we
should
i'm kind of thinking out loud here when
i'm gonna do some copy pasta
action
there might be a case
for putting all these hp growths for all
these different classes in our own file
like a single file that has them all
declared and then just making a base
class and letting people instantiate
from that base
player character class or whatever you
know there's there's some other ways of
arranging this is basically what i'm
saying
and uh that that makes it a little
complicated you know with hp of 14
that's not a ton lower than the warrior
i feel like this guy's cleric might make
a pretty good tank too so let's be
careful about how we arrange these how
about two strength two win
that sounds good it's actually a little
lower balanced than the others because
if you combine the strength in the end
of the boyer or wizard they have a total
of five
so let's go like that that sounds pretty
good two and three a total of five that
seems a little more balanced this hp
growth being really low um yeah i guess
we can always balance later uh let's not
uh let's not get too crazy into that
uh but i i feel like there's these
aren't gonna be the most balanced
classes starting out is i guess the
point i'm getting to uh i need to copy
again let's copy from warrior
go into the cleric
or go into the rogue
paste that in there
let's just do this the fast way this
time find and replace
just did a little control h there
changes hp growth to whatever we agreed
on 13
base strength let's go with
three in base and ii
how's that gonna
see that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense for me maybe
because
because if strength
uh determines your melee damage and
rogue's supposed to be the highest
consistent melee damage it should
probably be higher but it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense you would think the
warrior would have more muscle so i'm
getting these like conflicting logic
senses in my head it's uh
all i'm really saying but we're going to
go with it for now and we're going to
stick with these we might change them
later once we get more into combat and
we're theorizing how combat works and we
want to balance that out better but for
the sake of keeping the c plus plus
going we're going to stick with these
numbers that we've chosen right now
and that's uh that's basically it we've
got the main classes going we still
haven't instantiated any of this stuff
there's just a bunch of header files but
we could in theory start instantiated
them like uh
we have warrior one right here
and we could have uh let's just do it
real quick
well there's one and uh let's make a
cleric
clear one and we'll make a rogue
uh
rogue one
and of course we need to include these
classes
uh actually you know let's let's kind of
simplify these classes a bit and we're
just gonna make like a header that
includes them all this just so we don't
have to include all four of them all the
time and we'll just make a header called
all classes
right and it's just going to have
this simple thing of include
uh
rogue.h and include you know you see
where i'm going with this
uh you don't have to do this this is
just
i honestly i wouldn't even recommend
this in most cases but i'm just being
i'm being a lazy coder that's what it
comes down to
it doesn't really hurt
if it does leave a comment and tell me
why it hurts because i'm not really sure
why it would other than it's more files
on your file it's kind of annoying maybe
sometimes right but now what we can do
is we could actually like
just do a little cl and see if these
actually have the stats we think they
have that would be kind of cool right so
we could go standard c out
uh
oops
and we'll just go through all of them
like uh
in a second here i'll just type all
these up i'm just gonna put some basic
formatting in here
like warrior hp
uh oh yeah i'm gonna pause this type it
all out because it's going to be a bit
lengthy
okay so we're just going to do something
like this we'll use standard cl from the
i o stream and we're just going to say
warrior uh we'll make a new line here
and then we'll make like a little dash
on this new line say max hp and then
we'll uh
this just keeps c outing and we'll say
warrior one get max hp that's going to
say the warriors max hp and then we'll
go to another
we have another new line character there
and we'll say
or one dot
get uh what else do we want here we want
strength
so
let's see how do we set that here
now if we look at this it's inherited
it's private wait
oh yeah the stat lock
everything's public in the stat block so
it's not made like our hp is which is
actually quite dangerous because we
could like set it so let's actually
just go ahead and make those private
that would be kind of a good idea i'm
going to hack away real quick here
usually
it's kind of standard
practice to
put the private at the bottom and also
let's just turn this into a class
so we could even in theory since classes
default to private we could have all the
private ones at the top without having
to declare any of this stuff these are
all private right and then we could make
some quick getter and setters which it
might be annoying to some people but if
we don't want them to be like just
manually modified on the fly by like an
end use programmer this is more of like
this is more of a library type thing for
someone that's making a library they
want to control how it's used if you're
just writing your own piece of software
and you know what you're doing
you don't really necessarily need to use
getters and setters just throwing that
out there
but it's sort of good practice too
especially if you're sharing code it's
more about the sharing code because you
don't want like you base it makes it
clear what the intention of the code is
to other people that are using it it's
like oh i'm not allowed to modify this
there must be some
special intentions here that if i modify
it's going to mess things up and that's
that's
that's a pretty reasonable thing
so uh yeah just throwing that all out
there because some people don't quite
know that but if you're solo dev only
you working on it you don't need to use
getters and setters let's be real it
doesn't matter
but we're going to because it's good
practice so we're going to return set
type
get strength
yes
all right
turn
strength
oh what
we twain need to
return
okay
promise isn't going on much longer uh
we're actually in the final stretch here
i just want to kind of get this last
example going on here
and get intellect
so now the only way to set these
actually is with the default constructor
we'll have to get like a level up system
uh to increase them later or maybe if
people are like wearing certain items to
drink a consumable it temporarily buffs
them we'll figure that out all later
with the with the buff system but now
here with warrior one you should be able
to call uh get strength is the point
and uh
oh we also want
let's separate this out so after every
new line we're going to manually make a
new line also in our code that way it's
clear to us where the new lines are
oopsie daisy so it would be one right
here all right so uh this here would be
um
uh current strength or just strength
strength
yeah and you can probably see where i'm
going this so i'll write out a little
bit more of this and then i'll uh i'll
do like a pause break and type up the
rest here and uh
we'll go from there
so there's the strength uh we got a new
line there let's just copy this line
down
and we'll call this one intellect
and get intellect
very good
and now that we're done we can end that
and if we hit run here see we're in
debug x64 that's fine we have never
built this before so this is going to be
our first build if we don't have any
errors i'm going to be legit surprised
because usually do all right very good
and looks like we got some really
strange things here we got the max hp
right it looks like when it tried to
output the strength it outputs a a
triangle
and uh for intellect it outputted a uh a
smiley face
i'm sorry this is actually
this makes me laugh
nobody uses these small this smaller
variables so c out probably doesn't even
know what to do with them by default
windows doesn't like that small
variables so what we can do is just like
a hotfix uh is just change this to 16.
it's not like it's gonna it's hurt
anything for real unless it's hit play
saying that this shows you a great
example of how easy it is to switch up
your types for everything cascading down
and a great reason to use these typedef
so actually i'm really happy that
happened because that's a really great
example and now we can see that hey that
was a bad type to use maybe for windows
in general i guess and unc un16
it's not that much bigger it's going to
be better for doing math later to be
honest so it's probably fine to go with
the un-16 since we're going to be
matching with strength and intellect for
combat later and yeah you can see the
console actually knows how to output
those variables but
that was that was good stuff
all right so we can see you got the
correct strength got the correct
intellect and we can we can cascade this
down like we can just you know basically
do this for all of them and make sure
they work and this is essentially what
you would do
with a giant test file except you would
compare these and have them spit out
pass fail
uh type things so this is essentially a
test file we're going to delete this
later don't worry
uh but
uh you know like we do this for wizard
here oops scoop soups quiz so i'm just
going to do that real quick here
and change this all
to
wizard
go with the cleric for the next one and
we'll just like confirm that all these
look correct basically and that'll be a
nice little initial test for us to to
end on and there's our rogue i copied
that one too many times i'm going to
press my auto format key to kind of
clean this up there we go and now we'll
hit run again and
boom let's see if these all look correct
yeah
looks good on the warrior i'll zoom this
in a little bit looks good on the wizard
looks good on the cleric looks good on
the rope so so far we're going real good
everything's kind of calculating as
expected and we've got a nice little
base system of our classes with
different hp's different uh strengths
and analytics and we can go from there
thanks for watching don't forget to hit
all the buttons on youtube you can
support me on patreon links down below
links down for
below for anything else that i
may have mentioned here hopefully don't
forget to leave them and i'll see you
guys in the next one peace out